[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is an
author and associate professor of
philosophy at the College of William and
Mary Chris Fryman
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me all right man we're gonna do
philosophy for an hour are you ready
sounds good yeah you are prepared
I feel the jacket shirt combo it's very
philosophy I said give me the Reuben
yeah all right let's talk philosophy
because I think one of the things that I
try to do on this show is I talk about
philosophies more than people ideas
board than people and it seems to me we
live in a time where we don't do a lot
of philosophy and idea stuff well and I
guess that's maybe why why people are
watching this so let's do a little
philosophy 101 okay with you give me
just some of the basics of what people
should understand about philosophy okay
well yeah it's a great question yes I
might take the hour but yeah so I think
you know at the fundamental level
philosophy is about challenging
assumptions I think one thing that makes
philosophy different from other sorts of
academic disciplines is that you can't
really take anything for granted so when
you're you know doing philosophy you
have to justify why killing people is
wrong for example why feeding the hungry
is good and all of these things that we
take for granted at the level of
everyday life philosophy calls into
question and I think that's really
important and so the kinds of
philosophical questions that I'm most
interested in are ones having to do with
moral right and wrong justice injustice
the moral importance of economic
equality these sorts of things and also
the the ethics of public policy so for
example one thing that non philosophical
disciplines can do is make predictions
about what a given policy is likely to
do so while opening the borders lead to
higher unemployment higher GDP something
like that but all things considered they
can't really tell us what the right
thing to do is we say okay suppose it
turns out that opening borders will
slightly increase domestic unemployment
but it also will mean that certain
workers in the developing world will see
their incomes rise by 300% for example
this leaves open the question what
should we do
is that a trade-off that we should make
and that's really what philosophy tries
to answer is what should we do all
things considered alright so in a little
bit we're gonna get to some of your
moral philosophies that you care about
in economic philosophies and immigration
and a bunch of other things in just a
little bit but first I'm curious what
got you interested in philosophy in the
first place yeah that's a good question
so I think it was doing philosophy
before I realized I was doing philosophy
because arguing what's a good-natured
arguing was the family tradition in my
household so ever since I was a little
kid you know my parents and my sister
and I we would argue about religion and
politics and these sorts of things right
and wrong the economy and when I got a
little bit older I started reading
things and philosophy and economics
columns articles and things like that
and I realized that there was this kind
of formal discipline called philosophy
where you could argue about right and
wrong and justice and injustice and if
you were very lucky you could get a job
doing this if I get paid to do this not
a lot of not a lot of jobs not paid very
much either
but it's kind of like saying you know
you can get paid to eat ice cream for a
living I thought okay that's that's a
pretty good gig if I can get it and you
know that was kind of the start of the
trajectory into philosophy yeah you know
it's interesting because I came from a
very similar family in that regard where
we argued about everything from
economics and religion and all of those
things and I guess perhaps it this is
what led you here it's kind of what led
me here as well but we're missing that
these days don't you think like that
must infuriate you as someone that cares
about ideas when you watch the news and
watch all these people that are aren't
arguing from like a principled position
or something like a philosophically
thought-out position but just from like
a party place or a partisan place must
drive you nuts
it does it does because right I care
about ideas I care fundamentally about
good arguments so this is something that
I hope happens to my students in my
classes is they come in with a set of
preconceptions they have you know
they're partisan political believes
everybody does I have my partisan
political beliefs but I hope we can try
as hard as we can to just focus on the
argue
think critically and maybe change our
minds even if it means admitting that we
were wrong or you know finding out that
we have different political or religious
beliefs from our friends you should
really just follow wherever the
arguments lead us do you actually like
it when you find out you were wrong on
something cuz when I've had the moments
on this show and the most famous one is
when I had Larry elder in here and he
just kind of beat me senseless with
facts and you know and we've since
become friends and he was on just
recently and and I love the guy yeah
that it was scary in the moment like
sitting there in the moment of being
beaten is not fun but afterwards when
you go whoa that's what it's about it's
actually pretty cool yes so I don't like
like is it in the moment I don't like
being threatened by because I got a
couple things I'm gonna but but
long-term I think that's right it shows
growth and the funny thing is that what
are we afraid of when it comes to
changing our mind and admitting we're
wrong what's really the harm in that and
I really I like the process of arguing
it's you know a form of recreation or
something like a form of exercise I
think I think was Edmund Burke who said
something like the person who challenged
my adversary is actually my best friend
or something like this so the person
that is willing to argue with you in
good faith and genuinely cares about
getting at what's true rather than what
maybe confirms their prior political
beliefs that's you know that's person
that I want to hang out with yes I want
to talk with one of my best friends
growing up his name Derry Greek so he
was all into Greek philosophy and all
that and he was my intellectual sparring
partner for them from from literally
from 12 years old till well past college
even now and we're on eclis we actually
agree more now than ever before which is
sort of weird because we both had sort
of reverse philosophical journeys or
political journeys but that's actually
what it's all about so tell me a little
bit about some of the philosophers that
have affected you so one of my favorites
is probably John Stuart Mill so he was a
classical liberal he so he's what's
known as a utilitarian and this is a
moral theory that essentially says the
right thing to do is the thing that has
the best consequences the thing that
produces the most happiness for
everybody who's affected I find that
view attractive in moral philosophy but
he was also a he was a
Bosko liberal politically he was a big
defender of free speech free discussion
in particular his book on liberty is
probably the single greatest defense of
freedom of speech
I travel with it you know I'm on tour
right now I travel with it it's a thin
book yeah everyone should have it yeah
that's right
yeah so what okay so you mentioned
classical liberalism
okay everyone knows my feelings on this
do you see any meaningful distinction
between classical liberalism and
libertarianism at this point I think
that libertarianism is probably a bit
narrower than classical liberalism so
but this is a matter of debate I don't
have a very firm opinion on this but
when I think of a libertarian I think of
somebody who says the state should do
the following three things have a court
system have police force and maybe
enforce contracts something like that no
more maybe some kind of very small
social minimum Milton Friedman negative
income tax type thing whereas they think
classical liberals are more friendly to
a more active state but I would also say
that I'm happy to say that libertarians
are part of the classical liberal family
yeah it's funny because I had Dom
Boudreaux in here a couple weeks ago
talking about this and I fall on that
path where the more I go down the
libertarian route I really like that
line of thinking I still think there's
some utility of the state yeah but I
think the more that you have these
conversations for me I'm finding it
harder and harder to defend anything
related to the state which is it I guess
I'm taking a philosophically fair
approach to this because I'm taking in
new information yeah yeah I I'm I'm the
same way so I think that the the best
arguments for something like classical
liberalism or libertarianism is just the
pervasiveness of government failure so
you know you look at where actual
government money goes not just not in
theory but in practice where it goes
what sorts of groups are advantaged and
disadvantaged by the state the
government just doesn't work very well
and so the same reasons why we don't
want the government producing food for
example are also reasons why we might
not want the government in the business
of save running schools right so do you
think it would be fair to say that if it
well if this thing was a slim trim
operation and is financially sensible
and we had people of good moral
character and the gravamen and the rest
of it but you'd actually have no reason
to be certainly libertarian and me
perhaps even a classical liberal you
might actually be more of some sort of
big government Democrat or something
like that I think that's right at least
from my perspective so as I said I'm a
fan of mill and utilitarianism of the
idea that the right thing is the thing
that produces the best results and so I
think in a world in which the state was
run by angels very wise people very
benevolent people and it produced good
results I would be happy to accept a big
activist government a regulatory and
redistribute of state but I think there
are very powerful reasons for thinking
that that's not the world that we live
in so I think that some of my audience
when they hear you talk about Mill and
what's what's best for everyone they're
gonna view that through some sort of
lens of collectivism which is going to
set some bells off so can you unpack
that a little bit right yeah so I for
what it's worth my view is that a system
that produces the most happiness the
most flourishing the most prosperity is
something like a libertarian minimal
state perhaps with a small social
minimum so when you look historically at
collectivist regimes say the Soviet
Union or North Korea something like that
these don't have a good track record of
making people happy when you look at the
the societies that actually make people
happy compared to the alternative they
tend to be liberal limited government
free market civil libertarian ish kind
of states all right so what are their
philosophers that's back did you you're
one for one yeah John Stuart Mill right
up the top I'll give you somebody who
you might not like although you might
not be familiar with them Peter Singer
who's a contemporary utilitarian and a
lot of people I think a lot of classical
liberals and libertarians aren't big
fans of his although I think they they
need not not be fans of his so he's he's
famous for a number of things he has a
number of very controversial positions
on a lot of things but one of his more
famous thought experiments involves you
imagining that you're walking somewhere
and you pass a small child who's
drowning in a shallow
Pond and you can save this child at a
very low cost to you all all that's
required is that you step into the pond
to get your shoes muddy and pull the
child out but this means you'll have to
spend diving all hundred bucks on new
shoes and he says clearly the sacrifice
of a hundred dollars worth of shoes is
worth saving this child and so this
suggests that we have strong obligations
to make personal sacrifices for the
betterment of the world's poor
maybe that's right as at the level of
moral principle for example but I think
a lot of libertarians and classical
liberals worry that what this is going
to mean is we ought to have large
welfare states we ought to have billions
of dollars channeled into foreign aid
and so on and I can understand why they
make that leap but I don't think that
follows especially again if you look at
the track record of whether or not the
government does a good job of helping
the poor and I think it generally
doesn't yeah so and I definitely want to
get to your thoughts on that so do you
view that sort of as like that's sort of
like a micro macro argument that at a
micro level yeah you'd probably do it
like I'm sure if either one of those
we're walking down the street we
wouldn't care that much about our shoes
and able to save somebody but at a
societal level which probably gets well
out of your economic arguments as well
the more that you keep giving over to
society the more that it keeps taking
yeah well so I think is individuals in
their private lives if they do a good
job of say researching which private
charities do a good job of alleviating
poverty in the developing world and I
think there are some then we would have
in some sense in some sense a societal
obligation to help just in the sense
that most people of means have this
obligation to say donate some of their
paycheck to the against malaria
foundation for example but I think that
doesn't justify saying we want the state
in the business of redistributing income
on a global level if only because it
just doesn't do a very good job of it
and oftentimes makes poverty even worse
alright so you are a blogger at bleeding
heart libertarian yes and I've seen the
site before and I checked it out again
before before you got here but I thought
the phrase bleeding heart libertarians
that sort of sounds like what a
classical liberal is right we got a
little a little more heart in essence
we're okay with a little more state yeah
hopefully make sure the people who need
it the most are okay but I think a lot
of people will see those terms at odds
bleeding-heart libertarian ya know and
that's a great a great point too in
light of the conversation about Peter
Singer because they do think that we
have and I think a lot of classical
liberals agree that we have this strong
obligation to uphold political
institutions that work particularly well
for the poor and this isn't job
bleeding-heart libertarians is knew this
isn't just something that popped up in
the last five or six years if you go all
the way back to Adam Smith he has this
this argument about the division of
labor and free trade he says you know
you were sitting at your desk trying to
make pins all by yourself maybe you
could do two or three in a day you have
a division of labor where one person
straighten the wire the other person's
putting a pin on the on the wire and so
forth makes us massively more productive
than we otherwise could be and then
through free trade or everybody's
welfare is increased but he stresses
that this is particularly good for the
poor because he says a society in which
we're very productive and we have this
abundance of material goods is a society
in which these sorts of goods are going
to be a lot cheaper and this is in fact
what we see and so a society in which
the real price of not just necessities
but also things that we might consider
luxuries like smartphones or something a
society that makes those abundant and
cheap is a society that's very good for
the poor so I think a bleeding-heart
libertarian or classical perspective is
hundreds of years old although you
probably we haven't done a good job of
marketing ourselves perhaps yeah how
would you actually define what good is
that's a tough one yeah so that's right
yeah that's that's a big question so
here's the evasive answer is that it
depends on which philosopher you're
talking yeah so some philosophers think
that so Mill has this view that the good
consists of pleasure but it's a
sophisticated view where some pleasures
are of higher quality than others so if
I don't know you have pleasure as a
result of shooting up heroin and that's
equal in intensity and duration to the
pleasure that you get from reading
Shakespeare there's something
qualitatively better about the
Shakespeare than the heroine and so
that's his view is that it's a life of
pleasure but where you have these
higher and lower pleasures other people
other utilitarians think all pleasures
created equal
other people have maybe more complicated
views where a bunch of stuff makes a
life good so its pleasure its knowledge
its living a morally virtuous life and
so on and this is a debate that we've
been having for 200 or 2,500 years yeah
no end in sight I sense I know where you
stand on that but do you want to
elaborate on that a little more well so
I think that yes it's a good cause
you're here yeah I'm here so what what
is good well so I think that good for a
particular person is probably what a
philosopher would call the satisfaction
of your informed preferences so
essentially getting what you want if you
know what it is that you're getting so
for example you might want the liquid
that is in a glass right now because you
have the belief that its water but if
you have the fault if that belief is
false because it turns out to be vodka
or something like that you might have a
desire for what's in there but the
desire is in some sense informed by this
false belief but if you have perfectly
true beliefs about the world and then
you've desired say that cup of water I'd
say well that's good for you to get that
water you're getting what you want yeah
so you basically believe that
selfishness is good no because I think
that a lot of people I think most people
in fact have preferences rational
preferences for the welfare of other
people so I would say you know most can
you make it a selfish argument for that
because the way I've always sort of
understand or at least the way I use
these words now is that by doing what is
good for me that doesn't mean I want to
ransack the entire world right I want to
do good so that it's good for my
community I want to take care of my own
house
so that my neighbor hopefully will be
like I'm next door to someone with a
nice house and we're gonna take care of
their eyes so I view selfish and I guess
that's a little more of an eye on Rann
thing where I view selfishness actually
as a virtue yeah so I think the
difference would be in at say a case
where you're you're walking and see the
child drowning on the shallow pond the
question would be well what is the
reason why you're saving this child and
and ruining their boots I think a good
answer to that is well because they care
about the child's welfare and in some
times it's true
that's a preference that you have so
it's your preference until you could
call it a sort of self guided or self
directed preference but I wouldn't call
it a selfish preference in the sense
that you expect in some sense this
child's welfare to directly translate
into benefits for you right but you
would feel good after I get it like you
wouldn't if you'd be a pretty twisted
person if you were like well walking by
you like well well how's that gonna make
me feel right after though you should
you should do what's right but I know
what's right can often lead to all sorts
of bad things yeah but I think you could
make a selfish argument for that like
you know that if you walk by a child
that you could easily help and you don't
you're gonna feel shitty after if you
have any shred of conscious right right
so I hope right so most non sociopaths I
hope have that have that sort of
psychological disposition and as far as
sort of what so I think also what
morality is more concerned with is not
just the good of the individual but sort
of the good of all so I think for what
the morally right thing to do is
figuring out the decision so this is the
kind of million utilitarian view that
the right thing to do is basically that
which produces the most good for
everybody not just an individual person
so it could be in some cases that a
person's individual good comes apart
from what's morally good so you could
imagine somebody who just has no desire
to help other people I would still say
they're doing something morally wrong if
they fail to help other people because
they're not taking that person's welfare
into account right so where do you think
morals come from this has been an
ongoing discussion on this show but
young you know talking to Jordan Peters
in a bench peer and Sam Harris and
Michael Shermer Dennis Prager and many
others and they're sort of a religious
argument I think there's a secular
argument for it I think I'm somewhere in
the middle I think it's a really rich
spot to figure out what people think
about things yeah so that's that's a
that's a hard question I'm not sure I
have a satisfying answer to that so but
maybe in terms of the religious question
there's this very old argument from
Plato the Euthyphro dilemma I'm not sure
if that's ever popped up in conversation
but the idea is basically does God will
something because it's pious
independently of God's will or is it
pious because God wills it and Plato's
view was well it doesn't quite make
sense to say that it's pious just
because God wills it because you could
imagine as a thought experiment that God
willing all sorts of terrible thing just
as a thought experiment that you know if
God willed us to torture it doesn't seem
like that would make torture good and so
it seems more plausible to think that
there is sort of an independent standard
of goodness even even if you were a
theist for example and you believe in
God and you believe God has this
intimate connection to morality I think
even on views like that it makes sense
to say that goodness is in some sense
independent of the will of God and so in
terms of what more that's a again sort
of an evasive answer as to what it's not
where morality comes from I mean I'm
inclined to say I mean it comes from or
what's good for human beings and maybe
other sentient animals so what sorts of
things satisfy our interests satisfy our
Preferences causes pleasure and pain the
sorts of things do you think that's
subjective though that different
cultures obviously have different
beliefs and different you know
moralities and all sorts of things I
would say it is not subjective in the in
the sense that different different
cultures having different moral beliefs
would show that nobody's wrong in those
debates so it might be very difficult to
determine who is wrong but I don't think
the mere fact that different cultures
have moral standards shows that it's
subjective so by analogy you could
imagine different cultures having
different beliefs about astrology for
example so some cultures think that
astrology is legitimate enterprise other
ones don't they disagree about that but
I think it's safe to say that there is
in some sense an objectively correct
answer about that same thing with other
sorts of scientific disputes right but
do you think that that objective place
does that have to come from God per se
or can it come from I mean the
discussion that we've had a lot around
here and that a lot of people in this
space talk about basically is does
objective morality either come from God
and religion or does it come from
enlightenment values and then there's
other arguments that it's only through
religion that we got to enlightenment
values right in the first place yeah
that's tough my hunch is that something
like enlightenment values so I don't
know I'm somewhere in the eggnog
dick space myself and so I think that
your philosophy guy right exactly so
it's hard not to it's it's hard not to
be an agnostic so yeah so I'm agnostic
but I'm also Jewish and so there's it's
all are the kind of questioning lack of
certainty and so forth right so I think
that there is that there's enough reason
to think that we have objective morality
even if you're not certain about the
existence of God that yeah we shouldn't
worry that morality is going to collapse
if people become atheist and agnostic
right cuz when I've had this discussion
usually with conservatives you know they
love to say well God gave us morality
United I mean your rights come from God
and for me it's like I think you have
whether they're got you know god-given
rights or it's your right freedom is
your right as a human being yeah or as
Optimus Prime said freedom is the right
of all sentient beings
you know like I think you are born free
I just think that's a that's a
humanistic approach or you're born free
the government can take away your
freedom it doesn't give it to you and I
think that's just a really interesting
place to go for all these political
discussions I I agree so I that's why I
think that there are right and wrong
ways to treat other human beings that
are just true independently of whether
or not the the state happens to respect
them and this is the kind of
enlightenment thought so John Locke said
look in the state of nature I would be
wrong to kill you or assault you or
steal your property this is just the
wrong way to treat human beings it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the state now we might want the state to
come in and protect those rights and
force those rights and so on but the
rights themselves the standard of the
right and wrong way to treat other
people does not itself come from the
state all right so before we get into
some of your the specific arguments they
make on economics in a budget how do you
think our founders got so much of this
stuff right if I'm going on the
assumption you believe they did right
but I mean every time I go to DC and I
go to the monuments and I read all of
this stuff and I just was in Philly
yesterday I mentioned to you and I have
now a copy of that little copy of a
Republican senator of the Declaration of
Independence off the alarm at the
resisting with like it would set off the
TSA alarms at oh this one's just
standard simple paper whatever
probably I'll set off some alarm
somewhere I'm sure if I go to San
Francisco or something I'm sure a
constitution would set off an alarm but
I assume you think that they got a much
of this stuff correctly how do you think
they did it yeah so I think that's I
don't know so I think that some of it
this is a bit outside of my my own area
but I think that a lot of them were
influenced by smart philosophers people
like so I think the law the influence of
someone like lock on the Constitution is
pretty evident the influence of somebody
like David Hume on people like Madison I
think that's I think that maybe that's a
matter of controversy in history but I
think there's some evidence to suggest
that so I think that they were students
of history students of philosophy
students of economics and this helped
them get a lot right and I think you
know obviously I think there were
mistakes in the way that they applied it
and you know the way that like
Jefferson's omission of mentions of
slavery and things like that but I think
in terms of like the fundamentals a lot
of that was informed by really smart
philosophers and economists
[Music]
you